les toi tu vas être en retard pour son
premier jour de cours on m'appelle cas
je m'appelle d'amis c'est mon premier
jour où cela rigole pas pris au sérieux
ah c'est trop cool pour réparer les
téléphones c'est fini les morts
c'est la plie de mon propre réseau
social s'appelle l'univers quand tu
envoie des ondes positives dans
l'univers univers écoute c'est l'heure
de la mise à jour
je viens pour l'audition vraiment y
arriver à moi et aujourd'hui ta vie
c'est jean un merveilleux conte de fées
j'ai une appli magique sur mon téléphone
et tous les statuts que je passe dessus
deviennent réelles ça fait d'être salée
dans tout le monde je crois que c'était
toi j'ai eu du mal à voir parce qu'elle
gobet la moitié de ton village police
semblait déjà tout ce qu'on peut avoir
telle foule abriter la gloire à même la
fille la plus en plus j'en ai rien à
faire de tout ça tu veux que je te dise
c'est un virus
j'ai vraiment fait la perte c'est
l'option et essayer d'arranger les
choses
[Musique]
à